where are we
so this is our studio where we shoot our
sitcoms and our game shows and our court
shows it's uh something that's really
durable and flexible and we're able to
swap you know sets in and out so this is
mr box office over here we have our
comedy game show funny you should ask i
might have to sit over here one of these
days yeah we have great people coming
through you know john lovitz and sherry
shepherd greedy hello sheri
[Applause]
it's great i mean you know you just want
to have a place where when you have
ideas you can immediately put them up i
mean this is our factory this is our
content factory
and uh you know henry ford 100 years ago
he's got a factory and he's coming out
with his model t or he's coming out with
his mustang same thing so everything
in-house you control what what it looks
like that's right what everything
vertical integration that's what you
want you know from a to z
[Music]
yo yo what's happening how you doing man
i'm well i'm well good to see you good
to see you so first and foremost uh i
want to start out by talking about your
journey so if you don't mind if you
would introduce yourself
i am byron allen i was born april 22
1961 in detroit michigan the great
detroit michigan
my mother got pregnant with me when she
was uh 16 years old wow a little black
teenage girl in detroit michigan in 1961
having this little black baby you
probably wouldn't expect much right but
thank god we're in america and i was
really fortunate my mother is not only
beautiful she's brilliant
and we came out here to los angeles and
uh we ended up staying
and i we just for a couple years slept
on a lot of sofas a lot of floors slept
wherever we could at friends
and my mother ended up getting into
college at ucla
and going to film in tv school
and she ended up getting her master's
in cinema tv production
which is why education is everything
right and she couldn't afford child care
so i used to go to class with my mother
and i would sit there in class waiting
for her to get out of school
and then i would go and watch her edit
for her film and tv classes
and she one day went to nbc and said can
i have a job
and they said we don't have a job here
and then she
said do you have an intern program where
somebody can work here for free so they
can learn
and they said no we don't have that and
then she asked a question that changed
our lives forever she said
will you start one with me
and they said yes
and my mother got a job working at the
nbc for free
and she couldn't afford child care she
had to take this little black baby with
her i'm sitting there waiting for her to
get off work and i'm watching johnny
carson do the tonight show right and
then i'm walking across the hall and i'm
watching red fox do sam from the sun
then i go across the hall and i watch
flip wilson do the flip wilson show then
i go across the hall again i watch
freddie prince do chico's man all of
this at a young age studio the studio
the studio i'm watching them do talk
shows game shows soap operas and at
sitcoms i said you know what
this is how i'm going to spend my life
making television and making people
laugh so is that when it hits you
that's when it hits you 12 years old and
i'm sitting there and i'm just going and
it was so cool because i would stay i
would i would stand in the parking lot
every day or like around two o'clock
because johnny carson would pull into
his parking space like clockwork at two
o'clock you look up bam johnny carson
pulling to his spot and i say hello mr
carson how you doing mr car your
monologue yes last night was great i
love that joke about so-and-so and he
said thank you thank and over time he's
like thank you byron he got to know my
name
because i i was there i would
conveniently be there by that parking
space mr carson that joke right i would
always do that and and red fox talked to
me like i was his best buddy like i'm
like
i would have absolutely loved to meet
red fox oh my god man he talked to me he
would come he was old school so he'll
come up to me chris he'd be like hey bye
come on come here he go you want some
cabbage you want some cabbage and i go
cabbage and he pulled out a lot of cash
a lot of cash he goes look at that
cabbage look at that
cabbage but see but my question to you
is at 12 years old right like when i
when i was a young kid i
i watched everything michael jordan did
i watched every game that came on wgn
and just like a lot of kids it's a dream
that's right it's a dream so for you
running into them you know that was a
dream and you hoped and you looked up to
them but yeah how did you start your
career like what when did you start your
career like after 12 when did you say
this is this is it this is what i'm
gonna do you know uh gladys knight in
the pips had a summer show and they
taped it at nbc summer of 75 i was 14
years old
and they had a comedian on it was gabe
kaplan
and i went knocked on his dressing room
door and i said uh wow sir you know uh i
want to be a comedian like you
uh what do i do he said go to the comedy
store i called the comedy store i go is
this the comedy story they go yeah and i
say so let me ask you something do you
like do you sell jokes or do you sell
gags like what the hell are you talking
about this is not a super it's a comedy
club it's called right i go oh okay they
go i want to be a comedian they go okay
we have monday night tryout nights a
monday night tryout nights they go yeah
they said you know you can go on stage
at like 8 o'clock but you got to get
here and sign up but you should get here
early i go okay no problem i'll get
there early he didn't know i was 14
years old i get there nine in the
morning so i get there nine in the
morning and i sit on the curb i
literally sat on the curb from nine in
the morning on sunset until like 7 30 at
night and i'm just writing jokes club
opens mitzi short god bless her so she
opens the door and and i'm thinking oh
my god i hope she doesn't look up she's
just doing her thing but my voice gave
it away she goes okay what's your name i
go uh byron and she looks up how old she
goes how old are you
i'm going i'm 14 ma'am she goes you
can't be in here i'll lose my liquor
license she goes and i started to walk
she go wait she goes you just stay in
the parking lot and when it's time for
you to go on stage i'll send somebody to
get you but you go on stage and you
immediately get out of here out of here
so i go on stage i do my thing
and this guy comes up to me and he goes
who wrote those jokes
i go i wrote those jokes he goes how old
are you i guess i'm 14. he goes can i
get your phone number
i go sure he goes he goes i may have a
friend who wants to write jokes with you
i got i we write jokes with people i
said okay i give him my number i get a
call one week later and this guy calls
me up he goes can i speak to byron
i go yeah this is byron he goes this is
jimmy j.j walker
from good times yes exactly he's hotter
than the sun right this 1975 right and
he says
my man wayne klein
says you're funny and if my man wayne
klein says you're funny then you're
funny
he said so listen up why don't you come
on over here
and write some jokes with me and my guys
you want to write some jokes with me and
my guys
and i go let me ask my mom
and so he goes oh my god he's got to ask
his mom
so then i heard this dude in the
background goes tell his mom not to
worry we'll have some cookies and milk
for him
and then jimmy said dave be nice so my
mother says yes i go to jimmy's
apartment i walk into jimmy's apartment
and sitting there is wayne klein mm-hmm
jimmy walker right
jay leno
and david letterman
and marty nadler who went on to write
and produce laverne and shirley and
happy days wayne klein went on to write
all of these people in the same room
sitting in the room sitting in jimmy's
apartment on sunset 1975. but just so
you know everything that you just said
is not normal i hope you know that
but name all all these different people
right all these different people i'm
sure you learned a ton of things but
what was one of the biggest things that
you take away from even like johnny
carson all these different people that
you came across at an early age love and
passion you love what you do and have
enormous passion for it i remember when
i said oh my god i want to be in
television and i want to write and
produce i said i will literally do this
for free
i literally would do it for free that's
how i feel about basketball that's it
you get that when you feel that way then
everything else is then the moment you
find what you want to do when you love
it it's the moment in my mind you become
successful
obviously
the different things at an early age
impacted you but i think one of my
biggest questions for you because you
were a writer performer
when did it change for you and you said
the business side you know i realized
early on it's not show business
it's business show
juxtaposed those two words and now you
can do all the shows you want learn the
business side a lot of people show up
they want to be elvis
now you got to show up you got to be
john d rockefeller were you learning
that the whole time you know what
happened i was in a negotiation and it
didn't go well on a show that i was
hosting and uh and i didn't like the
feeling because it was like they were
determining my value my worth and i felt
i was worth more right and i decided you
know what i'm gonna learn the business
and so i went to my first television
convention in
january of 81.
and in january of 81 i was uh 19 years
old i got i developed some of my best
relationships going just showing up and
my mother was saying to me show up yep
that's that's like 80 of winning is
showing up you got to get yourself a
chance got to give yourself a chance i
said all right and i went and i showed
up and i wouldn't leave i wouldn't leave
the lobby of the hotel until i met
everybody and i'd gone to that
convention for 40 consecutive years
40 consecutive years one of my buddies
who i met at the convention dick
robertson he ran warner brothers warner
brothers television distribution right
brought in a couple of billion a year so
i'm out at his beach house in malibu and
we're out on his deck and we're looking
out at the ocean drinking lemonade and
he's got a couple of labs and i'm
petting labs and he just casually says
to me yeah you know that television show
that once a week one hour tv show that
we syndicate called hbo comedy hour
where they would take comedians doing
their their specials he goes i gave that
show to a friend of ours i go why'd you
give give that show to a friend of yours
he said because that's a once a week
show that only brings in 10 million a
year and he says and i have my sales
people going out on the road to bring it
to do the first cycle of friends
and i expect them to come back like with
a billion dollars and i don't want them
he said quote
messing around with a once a week show
that only brings in 10
million a year and he was like hmm and i
and i said
wow okay
and i went home and the next day i
started my company from my dining room
table selling a once a week one-hour
show chasing a once-a-week one-hour show
that could bring in 10 million a year
that and i was like i'm gonna take
studio crumbs and i'm gonna make a
gourmet meal
how has it been with family and friends
over the years like as far as support
going from one one stage of your career
to the next you know it's so funny
johnny carson said you know what happens
is you know when you start to have
success he goes you don't change the
people around you change
and so i learned early on okay i got to
go a little i got to go the extra mile
make them comfortable i got to let my
friends know i love you i appreciate you
nothing's changed as a matter of fact
you coming with me i'm not leaving you
behind right you're a part of this you
know i have a family owned company my
mother's office is next door to my
office you're hitting your knock on the
wall you're knocking on her wall right
so my uncle is my chief operating
officer people don't know he's my uncle
cause i don't normally broadcast that
right so
i love my family and i've even said
right and i say to my fam i say to my my
kids my three kids i said you know look
i need to get that education because uh
i want you to come hang with daddy yeah
i want you to be here at the office with
me i want us to build legacy well now
just in case you're not feeling it then
i get it then i'll just take the company
public and you know you guys sit on the
board if you don't want to run it
whatever but it's about building legacy
well i just have to ask you what is the
most memorable thing in your business
career i'm sure there's a lot but i'm
just saying like what's one thing that
you was like
wow
like i'm i'm happy this happened the big
moment for me was buying the weather
channel
and the reason why that was a big moment
is because quite often as
african-american entrepreneurs we're in
the negro leagues and there's nothing
wrong with the negro leagues but the one
thing i always wanted to send to all
these young black kids an image
of the global leagues
we don't just do business in our
neighborhood we do business in every
neighborhood that's real that's real
when i saw that i was like so happy for
you you know like that's a big deal
thank you it's the first time an african
american has owned a mainstream cable
network it was the number one cable
network last weekend and so when you
think about what's owned by the big
concord you know corporations a news
corp owns fox news uh comcast owns msnbc
and
i own the weather channel right so that
was sending a message to all those kids
out there i want you to see yourself
where you're global just because you're
black you're not going to do business in
just black neighborhoods and that's fine
but i also want you to know
you are playing it globally right and
and you spoke about it a second ago when
you talked about legacy right and
historically in hollywood
it's
a huge lack of diversity right yeah so
what type of solutions do you see that
could change that don't play the game
own the game i've always been about
owning the game when i met my wife 20
years ago she's like what are you doing
i was working for my down room table i
said i'm building the world's biggest
media company and i've never deviated
from that vision and as i build it i'm
going to effectuate change for the
greater good for the planet because
there are media companies out there that
divide us i'm going to unite us look the
president of the united states is not
the most powerful person in the world
the most powerful person in the world is
the person who controls media because we
control what you hear what you see what
you think what you read and ultimately
how you behave absolutely so that's a
very very powerful position and you have
to manage it in a positive way and do
things to make the world better but the
reason why you're so important to uh all
of us and especially someone like me um
obviously i grew up playing basketball i
was in my backyard with my brother just
trying to be like mike right like i
wanted to be like michael jordan and
when you get to the nba
uh you learn that like you said
it is basketball but it's also a
business that's right you know you want
to also learn the business so everything
that you were saying just now about a
media company obviously i started a
a production company called odip and
then with uh
a few other athletes and guys in the
league we started another media entity
called players tv which is about
including right athletes that's right
right having athletes be a part of
something bigger than you and i think to
hear you say everything that you said is
in anything you do you want ownership
you want to own it and you want to have
a seat at the table right because if you
don't have a seat at the table and
you're not a part of the and your voices
aren't being heard and amplified then
you it's not a real democracy we we have
a bunch of white guys who own spanish
language networks and they can't even
speak spanish people in the gay
community don't own their networks
people from the asian community it's
like they're invisible you don't even
acknowledge them
women really don't even own their
networks my position is everybody needs
to own these networks and own this
content and you need to amplify and
produce yourself i'm about the 4es make
sure everybody has a great education
make sure everybody has equal justice
make sure everybody has economic
inclusion and make sure everybody has
environmental protection and you get
those four e's that equals the fifth e
which is excellence if you're successful
i'm successful your success is my
success my success is your success how
how do you know what business risk to
take uh you know i i i'm comfortable
with business risk i mean i'm a big
believer in swinging for the for the
fences i mean
my first movie that i put out i went to
a buddy of mine and i said you know what
i got an i found a shark movie that we
could put out and i said i need 30
million dollars i said i'll put up 15
million you put up 15 million but i need
you to understand something you're
probably going to lose your 15 million
you're going to lose every last penny of
this money but i'm going to lose my 15
million next to yours and my my friend
said to me is that your pitch
i go yeah i'm just telling you the truth
that's my pitch he goes that is the
worst pitch i have ever heard in my life
he goes you got my 15 million so he put
down 15 million i put down 15 million we
put out the shark movie ended up being
the biggest independent movie of the
summer we did over 44 million at the box
office and we still laughed at the story
he said everybody who's ever come to me
and pitched they always said i was going
to make a bunch of money you just told
me the truth and said i was going to
lose it all and here we made all this
money i go i honestly could not tell you
we're going to have one person buy one
ticket but i could tell you i would lose
money side by side with you that's a
heck that's a heck of a story and and
i'll tell you this um
i mean learning learning everything has
been unbelievably amazing but one
question i always like to ask sure this
may be just the personal aspect
for me but anytime i find out someone
has kids right yeah
for me because i don't have all the
answers i always say if someone had a
book on raising kids then they're lying
that's right because everybody is
different that's right but one of the
things that i i've
sort of seen or always noticed is that i
feel like your kids will be raised with
a different level of privilege than
maybe you you did that's so
being the way that you were brought up
you know in a very
moderate family i know i know i was too
how do you make sure that you keep your
kids grounded and at the same time keep
them motivated
oh i'm good at reminding them uh this is
my money not yours right right yeah
i want you to know don't don't get too
comfortable yeah you know so you know my
kids they are they know they are
they are privileged and they're blessed
but they're not spoiled and that is you
you got to work that but the main thing
is i wanted my kids to be happy healthy
and have empathy
and my wife
credit goes to her she does an amazing
job with our kids i i would take my our
our kids to school i remember taking our
three-year-old daughter to school and i
remember her telling us saying to me
daddy i see another homeless person
daddy i see another homeless person she
said daddy why aren't we stopping to
help them
and i started crying because i realized
what was it about me that i turned off
my empathy button and acting like i
didn't see that and it took this little
three-year-old girl to turn it back on i
said you're right and we are going to
help them but they want to help they
want to lean in and i love that they
have that compassion and that is so
important everything else we can help
with we'll make sure you go to the best
schools we'll make sure you're educated
but more importantly intelligent there
are a lot of people who are educated but
they're not that intelligent so
so we'll make sure you
you're going to be a great contributor
to this world yeah that's all i want
yeah that's the that's the biggest job
that we have you know that's that's
bigger than any
shot that i could ever make any game
that i could ever win and i bet for any
business deal that you could ever do and
that's how i'm playing it so listen i i
cannot
say thank you enough for all the
knowledge that you just shared with me i
appreciate you you got it all right
thank you
[Music]